الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد يواصل تقدمه وفق
اعلانات اوكرانيه متواليه بتحقيق تقدم
ميداني الدعايه العسكريه الاوكرانيه تنشر
صورا لهجمات نفذتها في
ظهرت فيها مدرعات برادلي الامريكيه مؤكده
ضمنيا على اثر التسليح الغربي ميدانيا كما
يتحدث قاده اوكرانيون وفي نفس الوقت تبقى
عين كياف مصوبه نحو باخمت رغبه في محو
انكساراتها هناك وصولا لاستعاده المدينه
يؤكد الجيش الاوكراني تحقيق التقدم في
جبهه بخموت لكن التطور الاحدث كان اعلان
وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه استعاده السيطره
على بلده ستوروجوف قرب دونيسك ليرتفع عدد
البلدات التي اعلنت كييف استعادتها الى
اربع في مقاطعه تقول هيئه الاركان
الاوكرانيه انها صدت هجوما روسيا في منطقه
في المقابل اعلنت قوات الجنوب بالجيش
الروسي صد ه جوم اوكراني على محور سوليدار
باخمت واحباط محاوله اوكرانيه لاجراء
استطلاع باتجاه
بمقاطعه لوجانسك
بالانتقال قرب مدينه زابورجيا يعلن الجيش
الاوكراني مواصله الهجوم على محور
تارنيسكفا الى الجنوب الشرقي حيث احدى
نقاط القتال الساخنه وفي جبهه خرسون يتحدث
الاوكرانيون عن انخفاض كثافه القصف بعد
تراجع القوات الروسيه جراء تفجير سد
كاخوفكا
[موسيقى]
ولا اليوم الماضي انخفضت كثافه القصف على
خرسون والضفه اليمنى لنهر الى حد ما قصف
العدو تسع مرات النهار امس و19 مره خلال
الليل
تتحدث هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه ايضا عن
عشرات الغارات الروسيه والهجمات الصاروخيه
على اكثر من جبهه مقابل غارات وضربات
صاروخيه استهدفت مواقع روسيه على طول
الجبهه الشرقيه وفي يوميات الحرب
المتطاوله يقدم الجانب الروسي روايته ايضا
القوات المواليه لموسكو في دونتسك تنشر
صورا لتدمير مدرعه امريكيه من طراز اوشكوش
جنوبيه مقاطعه
مسيره انتحاريه روسيه من طراز لاستهداف
مدرعه تابعه للجيش الاوكراني معارك محتدمه
وبيانات لا تتوقف من طرفي القتال وصيف
جديد تدخله الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا قد
يدور سؤاله الابرز عما عنه ما تصفه كييف
بالهجوم المضاد